okay so i wanted to tell you guys about  our school's senior scavenger hunt so  the scavenger hunt consisted of doing  different drinking games around campus  each task had a number of points like  this is me taking a shot with a coach on  camp this is us doing a beer mile and  this is my friend going into admissions  and yelling i'm not donating why won't  you people just leave me alone this was  playing flip cup in one of the main  areas we totally got yelled at right  after this it was so funny this is my  friend we're all cheering her on to lift  the weight she can't do it but she does  the beer woo  honestly though we won and it was one of  my favorite memories of all of college